et oui en fait les experts bas ils m'ont
trouvé quelqu'un avec une compatibilité
de 82%
j'ai pas mourir eh oui
[Musique]
[Rires]
le monde
écoutez jeune femme blanche je sens sa
forme
gasc étonnant c'est que là elle annonce
quoi 82 bon ce n'est pas non plus voilà
c'est pas 99% donc elle est réellement
débarrasser enfin damon
c'est pas parce qu'elle est enceinte
qu'elle vient d'annoncer qu'elle était
ans alors qu'en revanche sous l'ère du
vide et du garçon du t2 de romain c'est
pas la même du tout la mairie comme ça
j'ai participé à l'émission my au
premier regard et du coup j'ai une
compatibilité avec une jeune fille de 1
82% et d'un moins de 45 jours mon mari
j'ai pas bien compris je vais m'arrive
souvent de mari oui j'ai mon mari je
pense pas que tu puisses y participer à
une mini siens comme ça voilà c'est tout
ce que vous avez ils veulent à un accord
ça me rappelle la tête de ma mère quand
je lui ai annoncé que j'allais poser
famille affirmant c'est price van cools
et moi c'est un scandale cette émission
franchement ne devrait pas exister on
chie sur l'institution salon et du
maillot ou si non tu as garé là qu'il
nous arrive quand on a mangé une
mauvaise huîtres l'allusion
l'institution sacrés du mariage c'est
pas possible l'amour ça n'est pas déçu
non route
c'est un feeling et en plus dans ses
émissions c'est souvent mariés au
premier connard sa commande passée pas
des chiffres
j'ai pas bien compris la chaleur alors
juste là en théorie les deux familles se
connaissent pas 1 les deux des deux
coupes ils seront toujours vouloir lier
le jour ils vont se dire oui
après se voit pas et là surprise les
familles donc se rendre à la mairie et
bingo ils se connaissent mais la cmh on
le dit c'est chelou regardez c'est pas
vrai il ya un regret toujours série non
audrey le papa
fantastique
une amie de la mariée qui ni plus ni
moins qu'une amie annie passe contrée
nous la connaissons bien nos familles
[Musique]
ce qui se passait le truc non novembre
il ya d'autres régimes
mais je tombe des nues avait compris
madame vous avez compris tout ce qui
s'est tramé la situer alors moi je suis
en ces jolies mexes moi je me suis fini
moi je suis plus longue et guitare
michel au pif c'est une ex actrice être
alors le moment de tourner à temps c'est
bon ils vont se dire oui
ah ben oui assis là bien humblement et
ben le monsieur et madame coup de foudre
nadine a oui ou non mais un second temps
c'est émouvant
regardez
[Musique]
tressé ça me plaît et vraiment je le dis
ouah al adha prestance avait du charisme
elle est vraiment jeu musical femme a
déçu vous sentez-vous à prendre pour
époux monsieur romaine félix ici
présents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à moi la falémé - les mariages s
connaissent pas me navre que vous
parliez sérieusement vous avez l'air de
cette émission parce que vous savez très
bien que tout est bidonné
êtes vous savez très bien que ces gens
là sont des gens de télé réalité le
casting là il est affreux ils viennent
chercher leur quart d'heure de célébrité
on nous invente des compatibilités y en
a même une qui est compatible avec deux
hommes pour scénariser vous attendez
l'émission comporte 60 je pense que ça
match avec pas de dollars dont mais bon
c'est le bidon c'est à coeur joie en
croire as a déjà un truc à moi je n'aime
pas les déjà vécu et que tu as écrite et
un mariage sur deux déjà est vouée à
l'échec
cc prouver juste avant et dans votre cas
ces quatre sur cinq dans tes vous vous
laissez aller au premier regard ce
s'appelle ce soit pris au sérieux c'est
n'importe quoi elle a raison francesca
remercie alors jusqu'à une fois pour
toutes pour l'anecdote quand même ce qui
est un peu énervé d'été spectateurs
c'est que le magasin de robes de mariées
1 c'est nathalie épaules c'est les mêmes
que dans l'émission sur le mariage
m6 qui recycle un petit peu tout ça dans
la vie et oui mais là il a beau gosse
que c'est presque même si c'est pas en
train de préparer de la praye amour est
dans le pré parce que regarder là il ya
une candidate qui doit choisir entre
deux candidats et il lui écrit une
lettre quand même donc ça rappelle
vraiment varié de près je pense que là
vous enfumer les gars je pense que
l'émission elle est sincère et que ce
sont les gens qui ont soit un jeu télé
réalité c'est une émission que je
regardais que j'apprécie donc après moi
je préfère ça franchement que timber ou
qu'une application alors en un mot comme
en cent kevin vatant peut parler un peu
c'est bien ça et est ce que ça
fonctionne alors l'émission au dans la
main et louis saha bcc passé 3 millions
3 en moyenne à 2 millions 5
on est quand même sur une pente
descendante en revanche par rapport à la
saison précédente c'est stable à 2
millions c'est donc là on arrive sur un
donc fait ouais ça après tout public
voilà là on est sur un rythme de avec un
bon moment sur les cibles avec ayant sur
lille rennes et managers ménagères